The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So welcome to
Lean Thinking Part II.
We're essentially
going to pick up
where we left off last
time in discussing
the Lean framework of thinking
about value, the value stream,
flow, pull, and perfection.
Hopefully the video gave
you some real active sort
of visual representations of
what some of these concepts
might mean.
So let's talk about flow.
We would like, if we
have a value stream--
this is a patient value stream.
We have people
coming in and going
through diagnostic procedures,
and hopefully leaving in better
shape than they came in.
And we would like to
create flow in this system.
We have to think about
a bunch of things.
We obviously want to
focus on what is flowing.
Again, the value stream map is
a map that looks at the product,
in this case, the patient
flowing through the process.
We don't want to be limited
by organizational or people
boundaries.
It's not a value stream map if
it follows organizational work
or an individual's work.
It's really about the product.
And first order, we
want to make sure
that there's the minimum amount
of buffers in there, inventory.
Here's a waiting
room full of people.
That's not flow, right?
And it's interesting to me,
as a non-medical professional,
to just sort of observe things
from a Lean perspective.
I have had both good and bad
experiences as a patient,
or the parent of patients.
Sometimes it's this.
You're sitting in the waiting
room for five or six hours.
And sometimes it isn't.
I've had sort of
astonishing experiences
with well-organized
medical facilities, where
literally once, I didn't
have time to sit down.
They gave me a little
form to fill out,
and before I had finished
filling out the form,
they were calling my
name to see the doctor.
It was it was a well-organized
system that had flow.
But bottlenecks are
going to slow that down.
Buffers, essentially the same.
Wait time in between steps.
Sometimes that's necessary.
You have an expensive
facility like a CAT scanner.
You're not going to risk
not using that facility,
so people are going to
have to wait for it.
But to achieve flow, you
need to minimize that.
And one of the key
things to think about
is time it's an
essential metric.
Our discussion today
is going to really
be about how do we
measure and define time.
Time is sort of
an obvious thing.
But when you start thinking
about measuring and defining
it, it does get a
little bit complicated.
You have to think
about it carefully.
And the key is really to
understand the definition
of how the time is measured.
And one of the problems here
is that the terminology--
there's some terminology here--
is not standardized.
So in different fields,
industrial engineers and supply
chain people will talk about
things using the same words.
They mean different things.
Sometimes the words are used
in a way that isn't intuitive.
So rather than try to
teach you the jargon
of any particular field, what
we're going to ask you to do
is think about time and
make sure you understand
and communicate your
definitions of time.
And we'll actually have a
little exercise about that.
So wait time.
That's relatively simple.
If something is just sitting
there, it is waiting.
So there is work in progress.
The work that you're trying
to do is not moving forward.
That's wait time.
And it's also called
queue time, delay time.
Again, the terminology
isn't particularly standard.
The concept is pretty easy
to understand, though.
Processing time, on the other
hand, is a little bit more
complicated.
So now something is happening
to the work product.
Some sort of resources
are being consumed.
Maybe a person is working on it.
Maybe a machine
is working on it.
And that could be value
added or non-value added.
It could be an active or
relatively passive use.
There are multiple names for it.
Touch time-- I kind
of like touch time
because it's
intuitive-- means, in,
for example, engineering
or health care work--
someone is working on it.
Both of those fields are
very people intensive.
If somebody is working
with the patient
or working with the diagnosis
or working with the engineering
drawing, that's touch time.
It's also sometimes called
in process time or response
time in the sense of how
quickly can the people respond
to a demand that they
get something done.
And these things tend
to pile up in ways that
are kind of illustrated here.
In a simple case, if you had
some work you need to get done,
well, first it waits.
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] there
was an oven [INAUDIBLE]
shoes, and you
heat the thing up,
but then you would open
the oven to let it sit
and not touch it because
it was cooling off.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
That's classic, right?
OK, so is that wait time
because it's cooling off?
But it's occupying the oven.
It's not touch time.
The guy is not working on it.
He can go do something else.
But the equipment is used.
So that's classic.
And I don't have an
easy answer for you.
It depends on what
you're measuring.
If you're measuring
the equipment,
how many ovens do we need?
You better account
for that cooling
because they probably
don't want to yank it out.
It'll cool too fast.
So if your concern is the
oven, you got to count that.
If your concern is the worker,
that part doesn't count.
If your concern is the shoe,
it's in process in some way.
It's cooling off.
You can't say that's
wait time because you
can't make that go faster.
Another classic one is painting.
You can't make paint dry faster.
Well, you can.
You can blast hot air on
it, but that may or may not
be a good thing.
And that's exactly what I'm
trying to get across here,
is that the time has a lot of
sort of unexpected complexity
when you're looking
at these things,
and you have to think
pretty straight about it.
So you could be
waiting, you could
be doing value added
work, you could
be non-value added, but
still in processing.
We stuck the glue on.
Now we're cooling off.
We're still using the oven.
We can't leave the oven, but
it's not really value added.
Maybe we could do that
in a different way.
Maybe it's necessary
non-value added.
Maybe we'll call that yellow.
At some point the
processing ends
and we go back into inventory,
and we're waiting again.
Sort of imagine that cycle
repeated lots of times
to finish our overall process.
And cycle time is
our overall time.
There isn't a whole lot of
confusion about cycle time
means overall time,
wait plus processing.
There's some other names for it.
The thing you have to
really watch out for,
cycle time is cycle of what?
It could be the
cycle of a machine,
ka-chunk, ka-chunk, ka-chunk.
That's seconds.
It could be cycle of the
overall shoe manufacturing
process, which, in New
Balance, was an amazingly short
three days.
But in aeronautical,
engineering, cycle time
of an aircraft life
cycle, 20 years.
Cycle time can mean a
lot of different things.
You've got to just define
your boundaries very carefully
when you're talking
about cycle time.
So now we have a
little exercise.
We're going to ask you to tackle
some of these complexities.
I hope everybody held
on to this sheet.
You were using this before.
We call it 5Sing
out of existence.
You clean up something
you really need,
and then it's gone.
I hope that didn't
happen because now we're
going to look at
the times, and we're
going to do a little exercise.
We're going to add up the
overall cycle time of an order
from the time the
customer walks up
to the time they
get their hot dog.
The tricky thing is
these times are not
necessarily in the right units.
Make sure everything is
converted to time per order.
Is it time for a hot dog?
Subtle.
What's the average order?
Does anybody remember?
Two hot dogs, right?
And we got to
worry about rework.
There's some percentage
chance- we're
looking at the average--
there's some percentage
chance that things are going
to have to be done over.
So this actually
gets pretty well
at how tricky this
can sometimes be.
so?
Try to normalize the times,
sum them up, and use the sheet.
This is actually
a group exercise.
If you guys want to
divide and conquer,
or if you just want to
see what people get,
whatever, whatever strategy
you want to take to puzzle
this out is fine.
But you only have a
little under 10 minutes.
Why don't we give
it till, like, three
after to do this exercise?
AUDIENCE: I see
what you're saying.
It shouldn't take 20 seconds
to put a hot dog in a bun.
So 20 seconds to put it in the
bun, and then about 10 seconds
putting it [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
That's how I interpret it.
PROFESSOR: All righty,
what do we got?
One of the fun things
about this class
is our sort of unintentional
experimenting and work styles.
Some people were
just doing away.
Other people were talking
waving their arms and stuff.
It was interesting.
Let's see if what
this process yielded.
I'm numbering you guys
M1-3 and E1 and 2.
So first medical option table.
What do you got?
449.
OK.
Interesting.
M2.
393.
OK.
What do you guys got?
You have different things.
Give me a sample.
See, this is the table
that didn't talk.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
around 300.
PROFESSOR: Around 300.
OK.
Plus or minus.
All right.
And E2.
432.
OK.
There we go.
So we didn't exactly agree.
We're going to give you
guys sort of an answer sheet
later so you can figure out.
But it sort of
illustrates the issue
of the squirminess of this.
It's a very simple process.
We gave you the times.
But how do you
interpret them exactly?
How do you do the rework?
Do you average that in?
Probably the most
reasonable thing to do
would be to add 10% to
all of the things that
might have to be done over.
But there's actually a
couple of do over loops,
so do you add 20% to that one?
I'm not sure.
You could interpret that a
couple of different ways.
More importantly, or
more significantly--
it has a bigger impact
on the numbers--
what do you do with
the stuff that's
kind of off the main process
loop there, the cleanup?
Do e you average that and
put it in as a sort of tax
against each hot dog order?
Or do you say nah, they'll
do that when it's quiet.
It shouldn't count.
And that's probably the
difference between the people
that we're up above 400 and
the people down around 300.
Does that make sense?
I have the 300 people
were leaving that out
because otherwise it's hard
to get a number that small.
This is pretty much--
that's somehow one second
higher than the number
you get if you add 10%
to everything and tax
with the cleanup.
So that's real close
to that number.
So there's different ways to do
it, and they're all legitimate.
But it gives you a feel for how
this is not an exact science.
And again, if we wanted
to get more exact,
we would have to go
to the [INAUDIBLE]..
We might have to stand
there with a stopwatch
and watch the
customers come and go,
and see what
actually does happen.
For example, the cleanup issue.
Do they really have time
to do it on the side,
or do they have to
actually make customers
wait while they do that?
You don't know
until you go look.
So again, an illustration in
how this can be a little tricky.
And we're going to go
even deeper on this
later this afternoon.
But for now, that
exercise is done.
Just an explanation
of something we've
had kind of across the bottom
as an icon for a while.
These things are called
time value charts.
They're useful if you
want to make broad points
about the use of time.
This is a typical
example, in a lot of ways.
Here's a process
that takes a while.
Apparently there are
two spans of four days
of solid work in this process,
as well as a lot of wait time
and a lot of non-value
added working time.
One of the key things
that this kind of chart
will tell you about
almost any process--
it's very bizarre if you
come up with a process that
isn't this way--
is that the big time savings
are in the wait times
and the non-value added times.
And people were talking about
the issue of standardizing work
and eliminating creativity.
What I always tell the engineers
is this is you doing your work.
We almost don't care how
you do it because it's
a tiny percentage of the time.
To keep the customers happy,
we got to take this out
and we've got to take this out
, and that's what we're going
to worry about.
And in a way, the same
goes with medical care.
A lot of the customer
dissatisfaction
comes from this kind of stuff.
If my son gets injured, I
take him to the hospital.
I was absolutely delighted
with the 45 seconds of care
that he received in
our nine-hour visit.
So I was not going to tell
the old male nurse who
was really good at
stitches how to do his job.
I was delighted with his job.
But there was a bunch of
other processes involved
in that particular
experience that
could have used
improvement, which gets
to the issue of pulling value.
I was the customer there.
I didn't really perceive
value pull in that experience,
although I've had
some where I did.
So what does this mean?
This is a kind of a
difficult concept,
and it exists on a
couple of scales.
Sometimes the easiest
way to think about it
is to think of its opposite.
A push system is an
old-fashioned mass production
system where what
you're trying to do
is optimize the
productivity of each step.
What that means is we
set up our machine,
or we set up our process,
and we push a lot of material
through it because that
is the most efficient way
to do most things is
to set something up
and then just bang
stuff through it.
And people sort of
intuitively understand that.
There was a question of why
don't we just automate it?
Well, to automate something,
you have to set up a process,
buy expensive
equipment, and then
when you're all done after
doing all that prep work, voom,
the shoes just fly
out the end, and you
can build huge piles of them.
But then the question
is, do people want them?
Are they good?
Is there quality issues?
Is there issues if you
want to change the style,
how hard is that to do?
So that's a push system.
A pull system is kind of the
conceptual opposite of that.
Stuff only happens if
the customers want it,
and it happens,
hopefully, quickly enough
that the customer is
satisfied by the process.
So it's triggered
by the customer.
And that is what New
Balance is really
striving for they had
a three-day turnaround.
So the shoe store ordered
shoes, and in three days
the shoes were manufactured
all the way from raw materials
and sent to the shoe store.
This both results in and
necessitates a smooth flow
with relatively modest batches
and relatively small wait time,
or it doesn't work.
So as sort of an ideal,
it's worth trying for.
And inherently there's
very little waste
in that kind of system.
Trouble is, of course,
that's relatively hard to do.
So let's think
about what we need
to do to do a pull system
like we saw at New Balance.
Pretty much requires flow.
You don't have to
have perfect flow,
but if you don't have a system
that flows reasonably well,
it's very hard to
make it a pull system.
And you would like to have a
fairly predictable cycle time.
Here's a bunch of tools.
We're going to get
into those in a while.
The point, really, with this
slide is that to have pull,
you need if not all of
these, most of them.
You have to have a
pretty Lean system.
And again, we'll get
into what those are.
And a pull system starts with
the customer, and essentially
the signals work backwards
through the system.
What does that mean?
From the customer's
point of view,
it means that either
the cycle time
is lower than my
expectation for when
my product will be
delivered or when
my service will be delivered.
Or there's inventory
in the system.
As a for example, I ordered
a computer a while ago,
that computer right there.
And I sort of mentally
budgeted a couple weeks.
You get the new computer,
put the files on it,
get used to the system.
I ordered it online.
And it came in from China
in less than 48 hours,
less than two days.
So to me, that
was a pull system.
It was way inside
my expectations.
So as far as it felt, I
wanted it and it came.
So that's a very nice system.
The system was actually
originally invented
by Dell Computer.
Apple's really good at it.
Dell still is, actually,
although interestingly,
their market has shifted more
to servers and industrial uses
of computers than consumers.
But they were one of
the original inventors
of essentially ordering
something on the web,
and then having it built
for you in a process that's
not really automated,
but the process
itself creates your computer.
People don't think
about the McManus order.
It's just you order
that computer.
It goes into the system.
That initiates the
production of the computer,
which goes very fast so
it can ship the same day.
And then they have a really
nice supply chain operation
so it can come all the way
from China in about 24 hours,
and you get your computer.
This has become pretty standard
for a lot of consumer products.
So the bar has gone up.
People are no longer
mega impressed by this,
but it's actually
pretty impressive
that people can do that
on the customer end.
A very useful concept
when thinking about pull
is takt time.
If I want one, I'm really
thinking about what's
the cycle time I expect?
I want a computer
inside of a week,
so if I get it in two
days, I'm delighted.
But if I'm Dell's
current customers--
they're people like Google--
and I want 100,000
computers, then
what we have to
start thinking about
is what is the pace
at which I want
those computers to show up?
And that's a really simple
calculation, actually,
and one that's very
much worth doing even
in processes that are less
predictable than production.
Things like engineering
and hospital
processes, this is
actually very useful to do,
which is to just think about
what's your available time--
a day, a week, a
year, whatever it is--
and what is the customer
demand during that time.
So if I have a day and I
have to see 16 patients,
what's my takt time?
Eight hour day, 16
patients, half hour.
If I'm not seeing a patient
every half hour, I'm behind.
It's not rocket
science, but it's
a way of understanding what
the customer demand is,
and if I hope to have anything
resembling a pull system, what
kind of time constraints
I have to stay within.
So that's a very simple
calculation here,
which is basically
the same one that we
did for our medical example.
This is for 40 orders across
a year of 235 working days.
Same idea.
This is basically
what is the pace
at which we need to do work
to satisfy the customer need?
AUDIENCE: So that's presuming
that this is like on average.
But what if all 40 orders
came in on the same day?
AUDIENCE: Right.
Yeah, that's right.
Takt time is an average.
The issue of irregularity we're
going to explore a little later
in the class.
It definitely makes
things harder.
On the other hand, if
you're dead on average,
then no amount of variation
is going to help you.
Variation almost
never helps you.
So you start here.
But yeah, there is
that issue of what if--
sorry for the aside, but
I was visiting Walmart,
one of their
distribution centers.
They have an awesome
supply chain.
They're very, very
good at what they do.
They had this enormous warehouse
in the middle of nowhere
with about a cubic mile
of lawn mowers in it.
I exaggerate a little
bit, but I think
it was a good chunk of a mile
long, only maybe 100 feet wide,
and as many lawn mowers as you
could stack before they started
crushing each other.
Not very Lean, right?
But that's because everyone
wants a lawn mower when?
Yeah, like May, right?
So sometimes you're
just screwed.
But on the other
hand, the reason
that they stack the lawn
mowers up into the big cube
is because the lawn mower
factory was working to takt.
They just figured out,
over the whole year,
how many lawn mowers they did.
And they were just banging
them out real efficiently
at that rate, and
they just decided
that the best thing
to do, although they
weren't happy about it, was
to pile them up and sell them
all in May.
So the takt still, actually,
over a year, made sense.
Just happened that they had
to keep them all until May.
OK.
So what's our takt time
at our hot dog stand?
If we had 50 customers,
what would our takt time be?
Somebody that's got a calculator
they can bang that out?
Four hours, which is some
number of minutes, which
is some number of seconds.
12.5 customers per hour.
So how many hours per customer?
And let's try to
express that in seconds.
Let's see.
We got 240 minutes.
So we got about four
and 1/2 minutes.
How many seconds is that?
Can somebody
multiply that by 60?
280 seconds.
All right.
And if we wanted 75 customers,
we'd need even less 192.
OK.
That's for 50.
192.
475 So we've computed a
takt time and a cycle time
for our hot dog stand.
And first order
doesn't look good.
Our cycle time is longer
than our takt time.
But that's a little deceptive
because there's two workers.
It takes one hot dog, this
one to order of two hot dogs,
about this many seconds
to get through the system.
But it's trading off
between two workers.
So we can't just
directly compare those.
Still, it probably makes
us a little nervous
that our takt time, the sort
of average time we have to hit,
is considerably lower
than the amount of time
it actually takes.
We'll save that thought
for a little later
and move on to the
thought of balanced work.
Actually, again, in this
example it's pretty easy.
We've got two workers.
If their work is
perfectly balanced,
they're kind of doing
half the work each.
Is that the case?
Don't know.
OK.
So we have this example
of a product that needs
to be delivered every six days.
If it takes 30 days to
build, how can we do it?
Well, one thing we could
do is split the job
the job up into five pieces.
And then they should
take six days each.
So that would work.
And as unit one goes into
the production there,
it takes a couple of days
to get things started.
Well, [INAUDIBLE] has
taken off by itself.
I don't have to push
the button anymore.
Every six days a unit comes out,
so we're making our takt time,
even though our
cycle time is longer.
But we have five steps, five
workers, five units of work.
And they're balanced.
They take the same.
If one of those processes took
eight days, would that work?
No.
It would take eight days.
get The takt time would
basically go to eight days.
So again, not rocket
science, fairly simple.
But if we look at
existing processes,
if we're plotting
this out, it's easy.
If we look at
existing processes,
they're very rarely balanced.
There usually is a
bottleneck process
or a problem where
one step takes longer
than some of the other ones.
So balance is a key concept.
Standard work.
We've talked quite
a lot about the fact
that if we can't
standardize work, then
it's very difficult
to improve it.
Single piece flow is a key
concept that's kind of integral
to the idea of pull, that we're
processing one unit at a time,
just like that
illustration, through all
the steps to completion.
That's kind of an ideal.
It works great on a PowerPoint.
Things are going
one step at a time.
No inventory.
That's great.
In practice it's sort of an
ideal that we shoot towards.
We try to keep
our batches small.
We try to make
processes, when we can,
line up so that the
flow is single piece.
That's kind of the opposite,
again, of a batch and queue,
where we make big
batches of stuff
and then it waits until the
next step is ready to take it.
This is a key conceptual tool
for any kind of pull process.
It's called a
manufacturing cell.
And we actually saw these
in action at New Balance.
The classic cell is
actually U-shaped.
People actually
arrange the stuff
in a U on the factory floor
because then the in and out
are basically in the same place.
Makes moving stuff
around easier.
There is even interesting
rules about whether they should
go clockwise or counterclockwise
depending on whether you're
right-handed or left-handed.
If you want to get
into the ergonometrics
you can get very clever.
But the basic idea is, OK,
if we have some tasks that
can be balanced,
that can be made
to take about the
same time and that
aren't dependent on a big batch
machine like those cutters,
then we can line
them up, balance them
so they take about
the same time,
and then put in a
very interesting rule.
Instead of a big, complicated
scheduling system,
we're going to say don't work
unless the downstream process
needs you to.
And you can tell whether
it needs you to--
you don't even have to ask--
by the fact that their
inventory bin is empty.
So very simple rule.
So in practice, OK,
everybody has inventory,
nobody works until
the next process
in line, the internal
or external customer,
takes product away from here.
Now task four starts to work.
To do that, they start
using their inventory, which
means three starts
working, which
means two starts working,
which means one starts working.
So now everybody's working.
Oh, and of course,
now we're out here.
So we have to go ask our
internal or external supplier
for more parts, for more stuff.
If everybody takes exactly
the same amount of time,
my next click would get
us back to the beginning.
Everything would go
back to everybody
having work in front of them.
So they stop working.
No inventory.
Direct customer pull.
It's just triggered by the
customer taking the item out
of the inventory
of one at the end.
In the real world, some
tasks, maybe the balance
isn't perfect, these
tasks finish first.
They notice now that there
is inventory sitting there
because this task is
not ready to take it,
so they're finished.
They stop working.
That seems inefficient,
but what good
does it do if they keep working?
What happens if
they keep working?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it just
creates more inventory.
We can just pile
up inventory here.
That would be a waste
of overproduction.
So that's very
simple, but this is
very practical in the
manufacturing system.
And conceptually, you
can use it for things
like engineering work.
Rapid drawing release,
people have set up cells.
That horrible value stream
we saw at the very beginning
with all the lines
going everywhere,
well, that was to
get one drawing out.
So if you just line the
engineers up like this,
makes as much sense
ever as anything else.
It may not be
perfectly efficient
from the engineer's
point of view,
but it minimizes, without any
complicated control system,
the time the product
spends in the system.
And that's the advantage
of a pull system.
Another example of pull
as a kanban system.
We talked about that
a little bit before.
Essentially, same rule.
Appearance of a kanban bin means
that the downstream process
wants parts.
Kanban card or bin,
some kind of signal.
The difference here is that
we're no longer in a cell.
We're no longer right
next to the other process.
So we need some kind of signal.
Now it could be a complicated
order with legal and pages,
or it could be a bin or
a card, something simple
that we've prearranged
that says, I need work.
I need you to do work for me.
Of course, you have to have
standard processes for this.
You have to agree
what this card means.
But it does allow us to control
even a fairly complicated
system visually, and even
if it's geographically
or organizationally separated.
Again, a very simple example.
If we have a supplier
and a manufacturer--
in this case, we
have physical bins.
In the New Balance
video, you saw
those plastic bins
that everybody was
using to move the parts around.
It's very real, very
direct and physical.
If we run out, we send the
empty bin to the supplier.
They know what that means.
It means fill it up.
So they work on it and
they fill up the bin.
When it's full,
shipping department
knows that means
to take it away.
When it shows up,
the manufacturer
uses it until the bin is empty.
Back to the supplier.
Self-perpetuating system.
Even if these systems are not
particularly well-balanced,
or even if demand
is intermittent,
it will operate with no outside
interference, no management
effort, and minimum inventory.
About the only trick in this
is essentially how many bins.
If you only have one
bin, what's the problem?
Yeah.
You have to wait, right?
You have to wait
for the supplier
to be finished before
you can start working
again, which might be
OK if it's a low demand
product or something.
In this example, we have
four, so it kind of continues
round and round.
Worst thing that
can happen here is
if there's no demand,
four bins worth pile up
because the supplier will keep
moving until all the are full.
So we could pile up four bins.
That's probably not
horrible unless, of course,
they're really expensive things.
So there's essentially
a design knob
on the system, which is how
many bins, but that's it.
It's very simple.
And we can tweak it as necessary
by changing the number of bins.
OK.
So that's kanban.
Kanban itself is kind
of a visual control.
You see an empty bin, you work.
There's other kinds
of visual controls
that are referred to
generically, again,
with another Japanese
word, the word Andon.
Andon is kind of an
adjective that means
visual control, more or less.
And you can have, for
example, Andon lights.
Again, in the video, you may
have noticed in the background
some lights like this.
Very standard practice
now in manufacturing
to have a little
light tower like that.
Red means the machine
is broken or there's
some serious problem.
It needs attention.
Green means it's going fine.
Yellow means maybe were
behind a little bit.
It allows you to just look
across the factory floor,
see the state.
If everything's
green, it's dandy.
If there's red stuff,
you got to go fix it.
If there's yellows, that
tells you what to worry about.
It's only really useful if you
do something about it, though.
It's part of an active
management system.
Another one is the Andon cord.
This is the famous
counterintuitive Japanese
practice of basically having a
cord in front of every employee
that they can pull that
stops the entire factory.
This is very scary, even to this
day, to North American managers
because any disgruntled
person can pull the cord
and stop the entire factory.
What's that about?
But of course, the way they
use that is to draw attention
to a serious problem.
If a quality problem is
happening, the parts don't fit,
that's unacceptable at a high
quality production operation.
So they stop the line because if
they don't, that defective part
is going to continue
down the line,
get more parts piled on
top of it until you have,
essentially, a defective car.
So a washer or whatever is
turned into a big problem.
It's actually better
to stop and fix it.
It also provides a
lot of motivation.
Everybody comes over
and fixes it right away
because the line is stopped.
So the team leader,
engineers, whoever
needs to come on over
and solve the problem.
That's the Andon cord concept.
Medical example.
Virginia Mason Medical Center.
They have essentially
a policy that
says that any of their
5,000 employees can--
they don't exactly
stop seeing patients--
but all attention is
paid to this person
if they declare it
an Andon cord action.
If there is a patient
safety issue that
needs to be dealt
with immediately,
they can get as much
attention as they need.
And this happens quite a bit.
But it has also surfaced
a lot of problems.
And the real key
here, by the way,
is not that this is a very good,
quick problem-solving method,
because it isn't--
it stops the line.
It could be potentially
very expensive
over something very small--
but that it surface problems.
If you have a problem
of this magnitude,
you don't want to see it again.
So it surfaces the
problem and allows
people to pay attention to
it, find the root cause,
make it go away for good.
OK.
Final step, pursuing perfection.
This is all about not quitting.
There's always more
ways to eliminate.
There's always ways you
can do things better.
There's always ways you can get
the employees more involved.
So it's a continuous process.
And we'll be talking
about that more later.
Another tool, a final tool
for this afternoon, five whys.
The eight wastes
and the six S's.
These are the five whys,
not the letter, the word.
And the point of the five
whys is to keep asking why.
The fact that there's a
number is actually kind of bad
because you may not
want to quit at five,
and three might be enough.
But here's an example.
Possibly apocryphal example
about the Jefferson Monument.
Why is the Jefferson
Monument deteriorating?
Because they wash
it all the time.
Why is it washed all the time?
Because it has bird poop on it.
Why do they do that?
Well, because the birds
are eating the spiders.
Why are there spiders?
Because they're eating gnats.
Why are there gnats?
Because the lights
are on all the time.
Of course, I had somebody at
a class a couple of times ago
that said, why are the
lights on all the time?
Because it's in a
bad neighborhood.
So maybe five is not
the right number.
Maybe less is OK.
Maybe you need to go deeper.
So the five fundamentals
kind of work together.
Pursuing perfection may
send you all the way back
to the beginning.
This is kind of
a strategic view.
The tactics-- and we're going
to be talking about this
for the rest of the week
so I won't dwell on it--
are, in this loop, the
Plan, Do, Study, Act loop.
So whenever you find
something you need to fix,
you don't just
willy nilly fix it.
You go through an
ordered process,
and it is through a series
of these ordered processes
that you actually improve
your value stream,
achieve your flow,
push towards pull.
So we've actually gone
through a bunch of stuff.
Remember that huge
chart at the beginning
that nobody knew hardly
any of the turns on?
Well, now you have at
least been introduced
to all of these, quite a few.
I don't know whether you've
absorbed all of those.
Hopefully at the top
level, the concept
of process, the concept of
thinking about customer value
has sunk in, and that some
of the thoughts about making
value flow, a couple
of the simple tools
have stuck, particularly--
not on the chart,
but always a favorite of mine--
is that you've at least started
to appreciate the
complexity of what
time means in these processes.
And again, we'll be doing a
considerable exercise on that
starting in just a few minutes.
So that's it for now.